okay sessile the lion this dentist
killed him for those of you who a lot of
you have short memories right I get it
hence the weird voting patterns so you
have you have short memories sessile the
lion to refresh was a lion unfortunately
had a name and this dentist hunted
killed Cecil the lion all these animal
rights activists got furious Jimmy
Kimmel went on TV and was crying and all
celebrities how dare you kill sets of a
lion well there is one contingency of
people who actually didn't care at all
about stuffing the lion the people who
were being eaten by self of a lion and
his friend had an astonishing rate heads
the Bob way to die I think was tuned in
seven sadek's last year in Zimbabwe it
was - it was over 200 and I want to say
250 something so we have it up at ladder
with Carter calm you can read the
original article because they were going
we want you to come and kill these wines
please please there's petitions over
there to kill the lion what's happened
now lions line hunters are gun shy and
now there's an epidemic of lion footage
the the population is not in tech people
are dying left and right they're going
to call 200 lions in Africa this is true
Dana and I weren't joking about it this
is true because of all the problems I
mean in Michigan right they have to do
deer cullings because there are so many
and what's the worst-case scenario right
a deer jumps out and you have to replace
the windshield on your CRV over there
your child gets eaten when it goes down
to the watering little-little yes
missing yeah and that's just really it's
not good but Tom shoes comes in one week
put so well in next week you go on down
to get water from the well and you don't
come back this is just a perfect example
of leftist and we've covered this when
we went to I went to Mexico for the
client Cancun climate summit they are
anti people they are anti human at every
turn the Lions is just the latest thing
right okay let's anything that would
help people in these countries GMOs to
feed these countries no no no way okay
so we don't get to end starvation DDT to
stop them from inelia no it's bad for
birds X no D
there's actually there's actually a
charity nothing but net oh that's nice
you're providing nets to people in these
African countries who are getting
malaria well what do they do for the
other 18 hours of the day when they're
not in their bed surrounded by a net and
my problem is not with nets it's nothing
but net that's my problem with it
DDT works so nothing but net so DDT no
okay fossil fuels for energy and warmth
no no way it's bad for the environment
yeah but these people are dying yeah
okay hunting but it's it's a Torsen
shoot yeah no hunting okay so these
people can't have GMOs they can't eat
these people cannot save themselves from
malaria they cannot have an industrial
revolution as we had because it's bad
for the environment you want to have
these these these agreements like the
Kyoto Protocol and they're not you don't
want them to have hunting either which
allows them to have jobs and sustain
themselves none of these things and
every opportunity you've placed the
environment above humans you've placed
the Lions above humans you've placed
Mother Earth above humans you place
mosquitoes above humans really at that
but you plays bird eggs above humans DT
isn't even proven to be bad for the
environment there was one study that
said it might warp bird eggs they're
lions these are man killers they kill
men and women and Z's and your guess is
as good as mine gender scissors in sirs
the left is unequivocally anti human so
when people say Malawi tonight client
why'd he deny climate science well okay
I spent time at the Cancun climate
summit not only within the same day did
Ted Ted Turner propose China's one-child
policy okay go to go to the website let
earth better not come I was there at the
Cancun clearance summit he got he got in
front of these UN representatives to
thunderous applause saying we need to
effectively enforce abortion and a Lobby
will only have one child in the same day
they talked about the Kyoto Protocol
which they talked about how great it
would reduce emissions that would put
people who live in Mexico people live in
Africa they would never be allowed to
have an Industrial Revolution
all of these things that these people
need rich white privileged American
social justice warriors tell them no
March them on off into the desert to
die and then tell me to check my
privilege because I scored off the
charts and the SATs and I took their
black spot in the engineering program
not me specifically Asians because
Asians are the engineers I couldn't I
wouldn't trust me to build a million no
there's no way yeah the last name Fung
I'm gonna feel secure even if it's a
puddle jumper so you want to talk about
checking your privilege how about you
stop telling these African nation
Zimbabwe what to do whether it's lions
mosquitos or coal just check your
priveledge and shut up Lata with grata
we'll be back if you're watching this
congratulations you've not yet been
corrupted by the internet and your short
attention span I know mine went away
with dramatic hamster and then it was
just solidified with history of dance
that guy can really do the Ice Ice Baby
here's the thing you may not know this
is a clip from a full three hour radio
show you can see that full show by
clicking next to me I think there's
something else playing in another box it
might be another short video I don't
know I can't be bothered to do my
research you're still here